the jurogan experience what what did
that one doctor in the corner say about
uh
well what did he say about the results i
presented to him 459 guys who had a 78
improvement in a year okay that was our
uh comparison to what is no improvement
yeah
no improvement yeah and so and it wasn't
a long presentation they only gave me
like 20 minutes it was a three hour
lecture i put into 20 minutes
20 minutes for you it's like a couple of
blinks for the average person
so but it was it was good right but the
one guy said he appreciates uh what did
he say he was sitting there closer to
you
he appreciated your willingness to work
with people who needed help but he
didn't believe a word you said
hilarious yeah and there were like four
or five docs that did that
um but that's fine did you call them out
on their motivations
um at the end i basically said
uh to my colleagues across the aisle or
across the pond that if they continue on
the
paradigm that they're working they're
going to have as many suicides as we
have in the united states
because there was no rationale it was a
psychiatrist what's the scientific
evidence a psychiatrist used before he
put you on
not you but puts a person on
antidepressants what's the science
there's none what's the objective
science you feel bad it's
his perception yes exactly here we have
hard objective reproducible
clinical data so i presented 459 cases
inflated out into age groups into
what percentage of the people did best
are failures
i mean we have failures our failures are
um 24 people out of 459
were due to their being on medication
that blocked our treatment
there are certain medications we've
learned what medications um
one called gabapentin
it uh interrupts gaba which is extremely
important for
uh sleep so it substitutes in uh did
they put you on gabapentin no i don't
believe so yeah so i
i didn't go in what's the benefit of
gabapentin uh for pain and for sleep
uh for chronic pain and sleep that's
what they're using it for
but the surgeon general loved what he
heard and we actually want him over
yeah we're gonna do this big study in
birmingham england like over four years
so the surgeon general loved it yeah and
who didn't
the people who had um control
of the military project at imperial
college
the scientific advisors scientific
advisors because because you just
threw a monkey wrench into all of their
work yeah when uh
his name is uh colonel uh colonel tim
hodges the stood out problem pardon
that's the guy who had the problem no he
loves what he's the surgeon general
designated him to talk uh
reid uh alistair reed was the surgeon
general
uh was the shout out to alice to read
yeah
so yeah it feels like truth yeah let's
do it
so shut those guys like he came in and
shut him up and said we're doing this
we're doing it in birmingham
really so what i've promoted to do is um
got shut down they shut us down yeah
they shut us down why'd they shut you
down
they came back afterwards the advisors
and worked however
they worked it and got got them to agree
that
they didn't want someone from the
americas coming over
isn't that always the case in a movie
where you have these like
stiff british intellectuals who just
don't buy all this new research and they
they do whatever they can to stop it
except this really happens in real time
yes
do you know the story of hilarious when
those kind of stereotypes
do you know the story of igor um
what is his name he was just dropped his
last name anyway he was
at the first ob hospital in austria
and um zimmel vice is his last name
zimmel vice he was a obstetrician
gynecologist
and during that time they would go from
cadaver dissection
into doing vaginal exams on these
pregnant women getting ready to deliver
and they had a very high occurrence of
what's called crib death where the they
die
because they didn't understand at that
time they didn't have cots
postulates that they were transferring
infectious agents from the cadavers what
year was this
the 1700s they didn't wash their hands
right so zimmer vice what he did he says
ah let's put lemon juice
and uh lie together and we'll wash our
hands
and he took a 20 death rate down to less
than one percent
and he did a thesis on this and
presented to the first
obstetrician or gynecological hospital
in
austria and what they did what they
refuted his results
why if they admitted that what he was
doing all it took was washing the hands
because what did they say during those
times it was god's will it was god's
will the reason why the person died
and it was also admit that they were
doing things wrong
they didn't want to acknowledge the fact
that here's a guy that's an unknown guy
i'm unknown i don't have credentials
like these people we went up against
and he was able to solve the problem
but they refuted it okay like admiral
small
admiral small from the british admiralty
he's the one who treated the first
nutritional illness called scurvy but it
took 50 years for the admiralty to
recognize it because they didn't want to
believe it took that's how they got the
name limey's
they didn't you know all you need is
vitamin c in order to avoid scurvy
so the doctors where limey's comes from
that's right
go look it up wow yeah it's in my book
my first book interventional
endocrinology i talked about these cases
because they talk about the paradigms
and how difficult it is to get one
generation of medical
caregivers to change what they've been
indoctrinated in
and fixated on to something more modern
that maybe solves a problem that they
weren't you know able to
uh resolve so it would be admitting that
what i've been doing all this time has
been wrong
if i don't wash my hands right and i
can't take that heat
because i become the culprit now it
wasn't god's will
right and then you become responsible
for all those deaths that occurred
during your treatment that's right
yeah and that's part of what i think is
motivating uh
a lot of the resistance there the
science is there
we're seeing it we're seeing it
stateside just as much
it's ego right and then it's also
influenced from the pharmaceutical
companies
if i had um a harvard degree or if i had
a stanford i had some of the other
degrees behind my name instead of just
md [ __ ]
what would happen is they might listen
to me you know
one of the um or you might have a
different world view correct
i'd say oh screw it right screw it let
it be
uh one of the um one of our
admirals rear admirals that uh who's
been with us for about eight years
connected me with another admiral who
got me
to the fort dietrich army
medical research and development group
to
share with them what we're doing and
they were interested in it but they
didn't understand it
because they asked me where's the
antidepressants where the anti-anxiety
medications they're looking for
maintaining the status quo the only way
we're going to improve this is for
people to open up and look at the
science and say huh
i didn't know about this catch new
episodes of the joe rogan experience for
free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre on your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience